here we are here we go another week now
the show how're you feeling I'm feeling
good thank you
Eagles got the win on Monday night the
dream is still alive it's Wednesday /
Thursday which means josh is in the
building
[Music]
he brought himself a pretty cool sweater
and a hot chocolate how's your in-laws
they're good good
yes they actually uh Erica's mom texted
me yesterday and said quote my man Josh
vendrick whoa she's heard the rap oh
yeah also heard our discussion about
magic Mondays in Atlanta oh I hope not
well Josh's didn't laws don't worry he
would never be seen at magic Mondays in
Atlanta my first question is do they say
so you're into magic no they didn't
bring it up or just go oh there's some
magic that goes on here got out again
- Kevin underscore raps follow him on IG
The Sims of love go anthem was awesome
it's cool to see people in the comments
section supporting him did you talk to
him anymore are we D and a little bit
yesterday he's pumped I know that's cool
you told me we're a low yeah I know
exactly where E is right by the Austin
yeah yep I know exactly where you are
Kevin nowhere near rod Simba I used to
wander my way down to those parts for
things that I won't tell you about a
little podcast ate a Whole Foods there
when you were in college I don't think
there was a Whole Foods there at that
time no i don't i think Whole Foods is
around back yeah but but Austin was
certainly like like somewhat cutting
edge with that stuff because it was very
canola so you know there was it was
starting to be into the health food
think just as I was leaving right yeah
yeah so I'm getting a lot this is
completely unrelated I'm getting a lot
of like text from people being like you
gonna be home for the holidays we have
our godly it's gonna be my like 15th
year high school anniversary which is
wild right do NFL athletes go to
reunions no I mean unless it's like
right like do you like do NFL athletes
show up to the 10 year reunion or the 15
year there's no such thing like unless
you want a Super Bowl that's the only
time you go back are you talking about
the reunion of the team or like their
actual high school be like their high
school reunions oh yeah I know I mean I
haven't gone
I've missed out I know I went to us like
some high school football things and was
a part of that but no I have not I know
we had a reunion not long ago and I
didn't go yeah I never know who like do
you go to reunions no I I see and talk
to the people that I want to talk to and
that's it
yeah I wonder if like reunions were a
thing and then social media came around
because like you really like this is my
one chance to catch up with people after
10 years and now a social media it's
like no I've seen your kids I know your
dog and that vacation two years ago look
nice man yeah and that's a good point
and I don't know why you waste your time
with kids kept keeping up with everybody
on social media either I just do it to
make fun of them
I'll be like God look at a lot of
Twinkies - the old man part of my life
leave me alone not where I'm like that
but I wanted I just go like I just got
to be with the people that are involved
in my life I can't try to be friends and
keep in contact with every person I've
ever known it's just too hard
that was the win I feel like I'm like
neglecting my kids and everything else
and they're too important we just think
about the match was like I got like
seven DMS from people that I haven't
talked to in like a decade right and
they were like so like maybe I'll see
you around the city and I was like no
probably not
life works yes we've run into each other
on this ride I just remember I was in
Nebraska and I remember Facebook was
just getting going
like really to everybody not just people
in schools and I member I covered this
guy and he was like living on a farm in
the middle of nowhere and I said man you
got to get on this Facebook like you can
connect to people's like don't you want
to see people he goes sir I live in the
middle of Nebraska I'm not trying to see
anybody that sounds awful and I was like
counterpoint taken I really like that
like he was like he was like my
next-door neighbor I described it's over
the hill and around the water tower I
don't even know what Street he's all
right Wow yeah Eagles beat Washington
yes they mark Sanchez at their
quarterback whoo unbelievable who
actually was having a good Drive until
he held it on too long and got destroyed
yeah Eagles now still have a chance yeah
and they're facing the Dallas Cowboys
this weekend right where if the Eagle
somehow pull off the upset in Dallas
gets really murky in the NFC East now
the Eagle schedule is a lot tougher the
rams the texans and then you got
washington again so that's good but the
Rams and texans are tough but a win in
dallas would i believe like that's the
perfect game to shake the media to go
what suddenly happened with the dallas
cowboys are the reigning Super Bowl
champions back like Monday morning will
write itself if that happen but I also
go ooh
the Cowboys played one of their three
really big games last week I got that
huge went over the Saints it could all
come back to earth what do you think
like this is this is the Eagles playing
for their Super Bowl in one game yeah I
mean I don't know I think all these
teams are in the same boat they're been
in the playoffs for two weeks already
like the whole NFC East other than the
Giants like it's do-or-die time
I do you though he goes will be more
desperate though I do yes certainly I
feel I mean the Cowboys are gonna be
feeling good about themselves definitely
there's no question Amari Cooper's
fitting in there also like a team like
you guys though when things are going
good they only get better like you guys
were last year when they kind of got
steamrolling it was like oh they're
there now they're feeling confident and
steamrolling quietly the Cowboys with
that running exactly and the way their
defense plays and feeds off of a motion
you guys match up with them still right
I mean you really do I mean your run
defense should be able to slow them down
you know your weakness of course still
is your secondary I mean which is really
slow I mean no disrespect to Adrian
Peterson let's talk about that well I
mean that was the first thing you text
no disrespect to Adrian Peterson that
was an amazing that he ran for a 90-yard
touchdown in his age but damn those guys
chasing him were slow holy cow worst
part was the corner Sullivan yeah
running with every ounce of his body
that's almond or LeBlanc which Raavan
low blow and it was a Rasul Douglas all
I know is he was running so hard and he
was losing ground with Adrian Peterson I
know it is scary like if that same run
happened against the Dallas Cowboys like
Byron Jones and shidou ba Woo's they
would attack him at the 40 like it had
been a 50 yard game would have run in
front of Adrian Peterson I thought the
ball of you times and then brought him
down but I mean getting back to what
you're saying though your Eagles have a
chance you deaf
we do and especially with you know big
[ __ ] part two at quarterback I mean he
just stands there and just throws rifles
all over the field
so you're telling me every time you
watch Carson Wentz there's a party that
goes it's my frickin debt a little bit
yes Carson Wentz is my dad I mean he yes
he is he's a bigger maybe a little bit
better athlete my dad was actually a
much better athlete than people would
remember before he's got hurt early on
in his career a bunch of times
but he does remind me of him the way he
acts on his man mannerisms to a degree
but he's just amazing like I know he
threw the pick thee the other night
certainly and hey they threw a few
screen passes oh god forbid he gets the
advantage of that that made me so happy
yes so they did that but man some of his
other throws I mean some of the throws
down the middle too hurts and things
like that are just they're phenomenal I
mean the throw on the run as he's
running to his right to Aguilar I mean
that's that's off the charts type stuff
so you always got a chance with him at
QB the touch to Golden Tate right
emergents Tate yes looking confident and
he looked faster all of a sudden did it
doesn't that happen I think it goes into
like something you and I have talked
about a lot like where's your brain
right you know when you're thinking it's
just hard to let it go sometimes you're
going wait okay what's my rules here
okay wait I gotta run this route this
way and make they want me to coach it
this way and sometimes you just can't
let your physical ability come out the
true thing is is Wednesday's one of the
great improvisers yeah and I've always
thought that you can make offense what
the Eagles did last year was a three-man
game yeah especially in the RPO right
and with Josh Adams and gold and Tate
golden is a great guy to read the
quarterbacks eyes and let me go back
like he's so much down that's what I'm
saying
and so if him and Carson can get on that
flow then they become very dynamic but
you have the way people watch Carson
Wentz I don't understand yeah you were
telling me I mean so many Eagles chats
and they're going man can Carson do
anything other than throw a screen so
I'm sitting there going guys I've been
waiting for them the throw screens all
year right
but the rollout to Aguilar the touch to
Tate the touchdown where he ran up
eluded the rush of rolled right like I'm
watching the game going Tim is there any
way we can give them an easy completion
does you have to thread every ball
through the needle other than the screen
pass everything is pat pat laser 15
yards between
right Abel yeah I don't know sometimes
when people see in carson wentz it's
it's really crazy it's just the world
we're in right now and we're fighting
this battle where everybody either
blames or gives the quarterback credit
and or six-on-six cuz carson wentz
that's the only thing they just see Nick
Foles won the Superbowl Carson Wentz is
in and that's got to be the issue the
the most interesting thing to me - is
that Carson I think is at least on
Monday night played at a level like he
did last year yeah and normally that
would impress me and mahomes has just
ruined me like nothing seems impressive
anymore no it doesn't unless you're
running with and throwing with your left
hand or like eluding a rush and then
throw-in 70 yards on a rope it just
doesn't seem impressive anymore
he's completely thrown out the scale
like Carson Wentz that roll out and
throw to Aguila I mean that we would
have been talking about for 45 minutes
it was good but it was the fourth best
roll out throw of the week that I saw I
mean it's really the because I could go
yeah
the mahomes roll out laser - Kelsey down
the field
Josh Allen backed up in his own endzone
running to his left laser there that was
scary maker Mayfield running to the
right one time during the game he made a
throw through like a cover - Holloway on
the right sideline there I can't I think
it was Jarvis Landry that one but it's
the new modern-day and I felt
quarterback is what we're talking about
with those guys and you're Carson Wentz
of course because it's it you just the
day of like oh we're gonna be Peyton
Manning or Tom Brady and sit in the
pocket and throw from the pocket all
game on it's kind of over right now you
have to be able to move to a degree
unless you have just this unbelievable
offensive line that can do that but
completely off the run yeah yeah that's
why I was laughing so hard Sunday
watching Josh Rosen when Josh Rosen had
like a 40 yard run joshua like go go
unbelievable unbelievable but the way we
did the draft analysis leading up you
said my concern about Josh Rosen right
he doesn't have the mobility that you
need in today's NFL right and all of a
sudden he's out which may have been more
of an indictment on the Packers team a
little bit but he was he had like a 40
50 yard run well I think 20 years ago
he's a pretty good athlete at
quarterback but that bar has changed
like we are we're I think if he came out
in the mid 90s we'd go he
pretty good for a pocket quarterback
we're happy with them but all of that's
changed because of some of the freaks
we've seen in the sport over the last
five six years how about this yeah
Mariota was drafted five years ago yeah
and he isn't even that impressive and
when he was in the draft we looked at
each other and when this may be the
greatest mobile quarterback of all time
right and now he's like the seventh best
athlete at quarterback right now he's
not as good as mahomes he's not as good
as Watson in terms of like athlete and
all that stuff he's not as good as Josh
Allen not I would say Carson Wentz
athleticism is right up there well I
think like movement quickness in the
pocket dancing you know Mariota might be
able to beat some of those guys we just
talked about in a straight-ahead race
but it's the ability to bounce around
and make people miss and you know throw
a guy off them when they need it and
when they need to like it Allen or
whence does I mean yeah it's it is
they're different guys I mean some of
these guys at quarterback now alright I
got a comment here from our YouTube cuz
we're trying to make sure that you guys
are listened to it is to God body their
God rot you he better have a six-pack if
he's got a name like that okay did God
body at the same point every picture I
see yeah god right he's not ripped no
you're right he is he kind of needs to
hit the weight room you know like every
time I see a picture of god it's like
I'm sure of God are you talking about
Jesus I don't even know how you did when
I see the picture of like the wispy
white-haired god on a cloud it's always
got a big belly like God has been eating
well and if you're God you should be I
mean he's Gandalf the Grey I don't know
that's what I always pictured God
looking like yeah I would say that if I
went up to heaven and I was meeting with
a guy in a crew-cut and he used it off
the rundown hello I'd be like what did
you just get a haircut Yeah right like
we've got friend do knows God if God but
why do we give wisdom to people with
long hair I don't know because most some
people I see walking around with long
hair I go damn you look like a sloppy
mess yes or do you have a job yeah right
but yeah but but that's but maybe that's
also the narrative is that God's chief
God was one you must treat everybody
right I don't know I also wonder like
how did they do haircuts back in like
medieval times do they just take like a
really start sword and just cut people's
hair I
it's a good question you know somebody
wasn't there like II go to sit down and
I get your front and your back just like
that wasn't a thing no no you're right
just like dull is something like dull
they just like scrape it off your head
yeah anyway Ducati four three three two
somebody somebody found limestone and
that's how they invented shampoo I don't
know how this works
anyway soda God body yeah three three to
break down whence his denial about his
leg and how it's affecting his accuracy
now whence commented about people saying
he's his leg messed up and and all that
stuff I heard about that I don't know
where that came from to be honest I feel
good I analyzed my mechanics all the way
throughout this injury I never felt that
as an issue at all at all
I feel really good with where I'm at
you've been looking at him as a human
for a long time
is there anything up with his legs
that's different than in years past
no I think maybe at first he wasn't
moving as smoothly as her explosively
and I still don't know if he's quite as
fast straight ahead like as he might
have been last year I mean last year he
used to keep the ball and read options
sometimes right yes and they would have
quarterback runs they haven't done that
with him this year I hope they would
break that out to a degree just do it in
the first series
I mean exactly think if you do it once
or twice that's all it's needs to be
done but but in terms of how he's
throwing for 70%
I mean his accuracy is like towards the
top of the league see this is where I do
it I was getting so many texts about
manna Carson's off tonight I I just I
don't understand that no the Eagles
offense is off nothing is easy and it's
not schematically creative it's gonna
sound a little Aaron Rodgers here-ish
dish they repeat plays there's nobody on
the offense that the team that a defense
has to go oh gosh if we don't back up
we're screwed against the screws no Tori
so you can't run right and then don't
have that guy like you're talking about
what scares our safety or corner in
football Collins yeah right yeah they're
all hurt so the biggest thing between
the explosive plays of your offense from
last year this year is last year you
were the third best running team in all
of football this year I don't know I
think you're 25th that's that's how the
plays get set up
you got really upset about the broadcast
when they were saying that on Monday yes
because to me it's just what were they
saying again that the
you know once isn't hitting the deep
ball as much this year I mean you know I
don't think they're throwing the D ball
as much I haven't Racine and I don't
know him like missing people where I'd
go dude how did he miss that bomb I mean
are they talking about the bomb he put
right on the money at the end of the
Carolina Panther game when there was the
pass interference that changed the field
position are they talking about the bomb
when you guys were getting your ass
whooped by the Saints and he threw the
ball deep down and get intercepted I
mean we're picking one play to
generalize the whole gear so hey it's
not as good this year for the Eagles and
their offense and it's not because of
Carson Wentz I'm not trying to be an
apologist I'm just telling you that
there's issues within that offense right
now the guys they lost and free agency
the coaches they lost everything has
changed the dynamic of the team you've
had injuries on the offensive line and
offense hasn't been as easy
it's literally him like we said stand in
there we don't care who's around you
throw bull's-eyes all day long and that
you know we're gonna give you a lot of
room to hit the bull's eye one more
credit before we move on to rams lions
of your film yeah that Jason Kelsey
block was incredible Oh on the Darren
Sproles I was thinking of you I know
well whenever we had a little boy
comment what did he really yeah he was
just like whoa he's pretty good he runs
good for offensive line I mean you run
15 yards with a dude one arm yeah and
then another guy's coming you go I'm
gonna take this guy I'm gonna blow that
guy Yeah right and push him into him and
the wildest thing too is there just
contact and then you see him get up and
then look and see Darren Sproles got in
the end zone and it's like he didn't
even know he was like I must destroy
these two people at the same time but we
you guys have heard us forever chasin
Kelsie's lateral ability yeah amazing it
is like I bet you if him and Travis
Kelce were running routes his brother he
would be just as quick I agree quick I
bet you he could like hang with Travis
in a 10 yard sprint I think if they went
off and on 10 you'd go damn I think
Jason might get him do you know how
there has been some blocking schemes
recently where the tight end has crashed
and the tackles pulled out for yourself
sure right can a center go out and catch
a ball can the person that snaps
catch the ball or no I don't they have
to be an eligible lineman yeah you have
to be an L
the only way with the like they'd have
to put like Wisniewski at center and
move Kelsey the guard you'd have to like
put because I'd love to at the end
there's a line of scrimmage and put
everybody to one side of them and say we
Cesar and there's a great I'm the line
guy here right yes that's the depth is
there any way that like you know how a
quarterback lines up under center and
then he's like walks to the side and
pretends they snap to the running back
yeah is there any way before they all
get centered settled right we're like
Jason Kelsey goes like he's gonna step
up to the line but then he goes out to
talk to the wide receiver could he do
that could the center walk away this is
how we're gonna know if anyone on the
Eagles coaching staff listens to this
podcast
Jason Kelsey there's a pass they weren't
listening they've just turned it off
right now they're like where they've
lost us on this one like that one no I
mean it's funny for that but I'm just
talking I mean they listen to your
advice about blitzing for football
people I guess they did I know I met I
got lucky but yes all right Rams offense
Lions defense I'm gonna start off with a
Nathan Kay comment on YouTube it was
awesome to see a team finally shut down
the Rams offense right is that accurate
cuz I will say having bet you know the
Rams by 10 right I was nervous for most
of the game right yeah it was accurate I
mean ok I'll say this much it was a
great game plan that Matt Patricia had
on the defensive side he was all over
some of the staples and did some unique
versions of their covers you see that's
like what what the New England's and the
Patricia's do is you know they might
play quarters coverage but the rules of
their quarters change every week
according to the team they're playing
we're you know one week it might have
been like looks correlational but this
week they'd like to do that so we're
gonna change the rules of our defense up
a little bit so that's where yes they
were great in that aspect okay they took
away some of the deep crossers and
play-action pass concepts that the rams
gash people with the other thing that
they had going for them more than
anything there are two d tackles or game
changers because they max a nation a
nation when they are in and they started
the game together and now you have
Ezekiel Hansa in who's starting to like
show himself a little bit they get to
that ability like we talked about a lot
left go where they can they can say you
know we can error on defending the pass
and we can trust the big
front for you guys to handle the run and
we won't get gashed and I think that was
one of the big things that gave them the
advantage of the game and the rams were
a little off on offense they were a
little off coming off a bye coming off a
bye option this dispute arose and I
really think few of the throws golf
missed I don't know if he dragged missed
him missed them I think he was being
very safe you know sometimes you gotta
take into account he might be being told
during the week hey you know hey we
don't need to take any chances in this
game we think are decent yeah we're
better than we think our defense can
really stop them so there's no point and
you try and do you know threat a ball
and the triple coverage and do things
like that and sometimes that can affect
a game I wrote down so many times in my
notes men teregoths having a bad game
and I check your notes and you didn't
agree I thought the same thing on TV
lefkosa know because like I was looking
at it sometimes when golf watches the
rush right he he kind of gets limp right
and like he doesn't throw the ball as
hard and sometimes it looks really
dangerous he just takes sax sometimes
yeah which I guess is a credit to
Detroit but I also found like sometimes
he throws that 20-yard post corner with
a zip yeah and sometimes he throws it
it's a little rainbow yeah right he does
but you watch the film and you even just
proved yourself I did as I said the same
thing and I promise you I said it to a
bunch of people even before I was just
like man golf looked like he was off and
when I watched the film I said you know
what he really wasn't as off the throws
I thought he was off on he was really
just being safe it wasn't like he
totally missed the target the guy was in
a pretty good spot and he just said I'm
gonna throw it high it outside if he
catches it great same thing with your
sack thing I think there was a few times
where yeah you'd like him to get it at
the bottom his hand but there was nobody
short he could just throw it to the
ground and he wasn't gonna just try to
force it downfield because like I said
they had people around some of their
intended receivers at times that you
know messed up their mojo honestly
that's how gosh I run the offense no
doubt there's no vision if it's a little
bit tight don't worry about it because
Shaun McVeigh you'll have a ball exactly
you wrote down in your thing about Shaun
McVeigh his ability to make things look
the same yeah and be different I said it
all year special but you wrote down I
love when he does it back-to-back yeah
he doesn't like he'll do it like
back-to-back and like maybe do the same
concept twice or the same play the same
thing but what
he does off of it you know like we
talked about sometimes it's the fake to
speed sweep and then give the zone right
or then it's the fake the speed sweep
fake the inside zone D'Andre todd gurley
drop back play-action pass and yeah
there was a few times in this game where
he did do it like back to back and had
plays dialed up that were just perfect
that kind of gashed their defense and
it's just some more the genius and what
I enjoy about watching them in office
having worked with Matt Patricia yeah
in this first year yeah we see some
games where he comes out there and his
game plan is fantastic right and other
times like is this a team that he's
coaching really well is the talent just
getting healthy now like what is your
honest read on the Lions yeah my honest
read is that he is coaching them well
they are in a midst of a huge culture
change in general and then some matchups
they just don't have the horses to keep
up like really even in that game when
when the rams finally just said like oh
let's spread them out and stop doing the
PI action stuff and doing that they were
at a disadvantage because now it's like
oh [ __ ] we're not really that great in
the back seven and now you've spread us
out and we can't play your man-to-man
across the board we're not good enough
to do that and we're really not that
fast and explosive in the back end to
play some of these spread zones to where
your quarterbacks still gonna be able to
fit balls into windows and things like
that so it they're in there in the myths
of a transition on their football team
and I've really been impressed with what
Matt Patricia has done I really have
done and I did I had doubts early on why
I wondered whether he had no one is
impressed you the most I just think that
their toughness their detail on both
sides of the ball different than years
past it is it definitely is there's a
there is a full purpose plan like we're
we talking about offense marrying
defense on a weekly basis their big
issue is again players in certain cases
Matt Stafford has had the worst year of
his career and then also like in this
game like they're often said no chance
in this game I mean none oh you wrote
you wrote like you can't pull a guard on
Aaron Tom know like you have none you
know they were Aaron Donald and Sue and
Dante Fowler were on a mission to ruin
world okay so they were just
unbelievable in the game he was under
attack the whole game the whole game and
then I mean you don't have carry-on
Johnson right
no no Marvin Jones so like two of your
best athletes are all exactly so I mean
there's there yet the Rams the fastest
team in the sport and you think like I
keep to leave and Marcus Peters like oh
no it's Kenny gala day and Bruce
Ellington what are we gonna do
like I know Kenny gala days a good
player or not trying to say that but not
that I can instill fear into you yet so
yeah that would be my point how much of
a keep Talib did you see just snaps in
the first half and this is a huge
recovery right now yes if I keep Talib
is ready to go by the playoffs yeah Aqib
Talib Peters with that front four and
with like Johnson in the back end and
Joyner who are like very active right
that's now we're getting to like the
Texans realm where the new way in the
NFL the Chiefs if they can get Eric
Barry back yeah a fort for that can get
after people and a back for with some
athletes how did it to leave look he's
worse case he looked pretty good he
definitely wasn't quite as explosive
straightaway fast they didn't play a ton
of man-to-man in this game you know and
they typically do well they do usually
mix it in a little bit more but I think
what they did in this game as they
basically said they have nobody that we
feel like can totally beat us so why
give them that man-to-man chance to
throw a back shoulder or have Marcus
Peters trip and fall as he's running a
go route and it becomes a touchdown so
they kind of played it like safe
coverage wise in the back end they never
got up in their face and we're just like
we're gonna jam you and not let you do
anything like that now also to the same
point though this is one thing that I
think the Rams need to fix I really do
to just go to the next level yeah the
Rams do too much on defense and you know
me I usually like defenses that do too
much but they're good enough
athletically they don't have today don't
need to reinvent the wheel they go for
the kill shot too much what is a
defensive coordinator doing when he's
going for the like he let's just say
there was surfer instance I want to say
it was second quarter third quarter
where I'm guessing they had a beat when
they were in 21 personnel some of the
things they like to do and they went out
and doubled both outside receivers at
the snap and all
okay great that's really cool and I'm
sure that's where Stafford wanted to go
but it left them in a total compromised
situation off the play action for the
tight end down the middle so now there's
the linebacker going wait LeGarrette
Blount running at me I got to take a
step up here or I'm gonna get run over
oh crap the quarterback kept it now I
got a run down the field with Toya low
low and that's why he had a big day I
just think they take too many chances
they could be bland and simple and still
kick people yes they do with themselves
a disservice just play zones make a
quarterback pack the ball once or twice
and Aaron Donald ensue or somebody's
gonna hit them and they're gonna fumble
and they leave themselves open to big
plays as long this is a rare occasion
when you ask for simplicity very rare
very rare they do not need to reinvent
the wheel you know it goes back to like
almost him with Wade Phil's back in
Denver yep like okay we don't need to do
a lot here you're really awesome you got
an awesome front for you got some good
cover guys mixed in a sprinkle of
creativity here and there in a situation
but don't overdo it I feel like they
overdo it a little right now the
argument that Aaron Donald should be in
the MVP race yeah he should be 16 and a
half sacks if he breaks Strahan
he's definitely winning Defensive Player
of the Year yes that's not even a check
but I could argue that he may have been
the most important player in the Rams
Chiefs game yeah III think there was a
number of games you could argue that it
he mean he's been a number of big I mean
Seattle baby ended Green Bay Green Bay
there was people open a number of times
I go Rodgers and then Rodgers had a move
or he got hit as he was throwing it and
couldn't do it he makes so many game
changing plays just along that aspect
that don't go in the stat sheet like
you're saying yeah he goes back and he
makes him a home's move and my homes
might have had somebody wide open but
now he can't throw it or you know or you
get hit as you're throwing or you change
your motion because you're like oh he's
coming from behind me I don't want to
extend my arm let me throw it a little
different he's amazing man this guy has
six games this year where he's had more
than two sacks in a game right that's a
career day for people and he has six
games this year like I bet you there's a
statistic where if
a team like I bet you there's most teams
don't even get to sex in the game as a
team right to sex by one player in a
game think about that's two drives that
are ending that it's it's huge
yes I know it's uh he is by far the
biggest mismatch in football right now
on the defensive side of the ball coil
max close he really is he's up there
like I forgot he had two sacks in that
game against Minnesota that was 38 30
was exactly right all right well if he
keeps going it'll be an interesting
conversation it will be Vikings Patriots
yeah what was one thing that you went
into the film expecting that you were
actually wrong about oh one thing that I
was expecting to go exactly according to
plan I don't know if it went exactly
according to plan we just think about
how did Kirk look in the sunlight
well not the prime time yeah it was it
was it was kind of you know that's why I
didn't play thought he got confused he
was like prime time you know what where
am I they were tied at halftime
yeah and they long Sun went down as soon
as the Sun went down your cousins
couldn't handle the prize ever tied late
in third quarter
yeah and then as soon as it started
getting a little dusky hmm I guess the
my biggest thing I would say the
Patriots played more zone in the game
and I think it's the same reason I just
told you about the Rams playing zone
okay I just think they said this team
thrives on the man 214 or 8 to 19
connection deep down the field we don't
really have any faith that they can move
the ball other ways on us consistently
so why take those chances to have you
know a one-shot ball change the whole
dynamic of the football game so I guess
if that was one thing I didn't think of
that would be the one thing I was
surprised by especially at the start of
the game I saw a few times in your notes
about Dalvin cook pressing you I mean
he's insane I don't know first of all he
was the most explosive offensive player
on the field for both teams in the first
half and you know John D filippo we've
heard a little bit over the last few
weeks like they got to run the ball more
for
just I don't even care about success
it's for the attempts and it's about
getting your best our most explosive
playmaker with the ball in his hands is
Dalvin cook and they need to do that
with him more you know they just go to
money long periods of time where they
kind of abandoned the run game and you
know he had a few runs that you just go
wow like okay let's get in the ball
again and then it just he goes through a
dry spell
um I'm seeing here you wrote down that
the Vikes never really made any plays
and Tom Brady they never really got
close to him no where is the level of
this offensive line for the Patriots man
where are they compared to years past
because if you think about it they make
the trade for Trent Brown right they
lose solder for the first time right
it's it's a little bit of a newer regime
it is yes so funny when I see David
Andrews on camera because he's like
every frat guy that I lived with right
like a hoodie with like hair curling out
the bottom he's like he was so man I'm
just like the center you know like but
but the offensive line seems to be
coming together it's just another
beautiful performance by scar neck yeah
it's a it's a it's a really good
offensive line I'm not gonna say it's
top five I think it's top five run
offensive line okay I don't think it's
as good a pass protecting offensive line
may be something that you're stacking it
over the top on the running game Shaq
Mason's the man that guard all you need
to know is they gave him a big contract
last year and when did the Patriots ever
do that that's right Shaq Mason's one of
the best run blocking guards in the
sport David Andrews of course is very
good in the run game so is Funi as well
and then you got two tackles on the
outside I mean Marcus Cannon has played
a lot of guard in his life he's a big
man who can move you in the run game
Trent Brown I mean he looks like he ate
two of you and then he plays left tackle
so yet they're more of a big mauling
group where in years past they were more
long and athletic and we're gonna mirror
everybody so Brady can sit back here and
Pat the ball and find people down the
field or do whatever he has you know
this year they're not quite as good with
pass bro but damn if you get in certain
defenses they will steamroll you in a
second Josh I got a line here that I
really like hit me it's when Simms
writes things that make me laugh ooh
yeah I just gotta find it okay here it
is
perfect example Pat's first third down I
don't know what [ __ ] defense they're
playing and no way cousins does or D
philippa or D flipo why is he calling a
third neat wide receiver screen right
that's why I meant to say that's why
he's calling a third and eight wide
receiver because he's going I don't know
what the [ __ ] they're gonna do on this
first third down who knows
I don't know your guess is good and I
don't want to confuse my quarterback and
hit make some stupid reads so it's third
and eight let's maybe catch them in
something we get a screen and get a
first down but I don't want him drop
back and go whoa what the hell is this
they doubled this guy we're not saying
you turn on the film it's that I've
never seen this before you're going if I
was a quarterback yeah the first third
down in the game you have no idea what
balichek's gonna throw you and that's
something you've seen in all the game
any game where I feel like dangerous
quarterback or Rodgers I felt like the
homes they dropped everybody out I was
like what is this exactly right so
you're saying that when I watch the
Patriots this week yeah that first third
down on defense if I'm able to bet live
action that maybe there's an
interception that's the play to bet on
you better be careful if you're because
yes
it's you don't know what their game plan
is yet to stop you you don't know and
this is Bill Belichick in New England
and Brian Flores and they're going to
bring something out there like we always
say that stops the one thing you like to
do so you're saying if I watch the
defense on the first third down yeah
it's gonna give me the insight to the
rest of the half what they're gonna be
trying to defend you I think so but
they're also gonna have one little thing
off of that to keep you honest right
where you were just talking about
mahomes game they all dropped out yeah
but that two or three times they all
came are they all blitz right and then
you go oh gosh well you know so that's
where I'm excited to watch the Patriots
first they're great that's all I care
about and the Vikings D is the opposite
of that they're just not multiple enough
for good offenses it's just too
comfortable for an experienced
quarterback at time I am reading that
John Dee Filippo's offense is just not
creative enough so let's confirm that
maybe he's not ready to be the head
coach that everyone thinks he know I and
like I've told you off air I totally
think he is head coach material yeah I
just don't think his offense is
developed enough or he's got enough you
know pelts on his horse
two notes on his horse I think that's
the proper phrase my dad tell us this is
what he went over with us but yeah I
think that's that's the thing with them
their defense is not their defense is
very good and can match up with people
and they do have a little bit more
d-line depth than yours past but it's
still a little too predictable I think
for the really good offenses in football
and that's why you've seen the Saints
have success and you saw the Rams tear
them apart and not that the Patriots
tore them apart but every time the
Patriots wanted to step on the gas pedal
the other night they did and they went
down the field and scored we're gonna
end Patriots Vikings with this yeah you
spotlighted two young players and the
Patriots secondary that you think could
be blossoming yeah right number one yeah
a favorite of the pod Obi melon Fahd
whoo yeah are we calling him a tight end
stopper I'm wondering if that's what
he's there for you know I'm always
thinking about a I'll Rudolph we'd like
to introduce you to OB Belafonte he can
jump higher right run faster just like
that Travis Kelce will have to play in
the playoffs so get ready to guard him
or Vance McDonald on the Steelers or and
you think that fits his skill set I
definitely do he's a giant for a
secondary guy like when I see him out
there and I don't see his number I'm
like who is this person and then I get
to the end zone shot and I'm like oh 22
it's Melanie still doing well he's doing
okay they're just giving him a few snaps
they're getting let him get his beak wet
a little bit okay he's getting his beak
wet they're that far into the future
that they would sign a player just to
stop a potential play off of yeah yeah
they would or just think about certain
areas where they feel like they're weak
at defending Tianna that might be good
at doing something they go we don't
really need that other piece there to
stop that is it that impressive no I
mean I just picked up the Cowboys
defense in fantasy in case I make it to
WIC sixteen of my fantasy young beljac
right there it's just it's look at a few
weeks head Josh she'll get there yeah
let's see was the other thing I thought
I found it fascinating every big third
down or pass just to end it all oh no I
had one more go okay go Jackson Jackson
man what's his first name
JC so JC Jax is he a rookie this year
he's a rookie this year undrafted from
Maryland we talked about him a few weeks
ago terrorist game right and he he
I can't where was he at Miami before you
Florida it was a Florida got kicked out
got kicked out so he's had some
off-the-field issues but his combine
numbers and his size and measurables are
they're phenomenal I mean he ran like a
low for four he and you're writing in
your notes might be time to put this guy
on an island yeah I mean he has the
potential to be something special
he really does they found something here
and what about your Duke Dawson key well
he hasn't really got out there yet he's
number 29 I keep looking for him just
going where the hell is this because you
know I liked him coming out in the draft
but there I know that they are trusting
him left go because they're putting him
in some very big situations and big
moments and trusting him to go oh you
know it's third and nine you go take
Stefon Diggs or you go get feeling on
the outside but for the most part what I
thought was cool on third downs for the
most part of the game especially if
Phelan was in the slot
he was doubled every time they doubled
him and then let Gilmore take digs right
so if Dillon got in the slot it was 30
to the McCourty twins covering Thielen
hold on which is hilarious right we're
gonna double-team you so you're telling
me here what does that double MEAP gum
you're telling me that Adam feelings in
the slot right and he looks up and he
sees a McCourty twin looking at okay and
then he looks a little bit further and
he sees the other McCourty try looking
at right I don't even care if these guys
aren't good I'm sitting there going what
is this the Patriots are cloning
defenders they they are clones those two
I have a hard time when I see them I
just
double-team with both McCourty twins
double team if they were synergy behind
those priors right like they they can
communicate without doing anything right
Patriots offensive players look at that
and get a little messed up by just
looking at wins they look through their
face and go damn you two look exactly
the same I mean I didn't put those two
before and I'm telling you I've been
with those two walked out of the room
came back in and gone [ __ ] I'm not sure
which ones which again I can't remember
I mean I've had to go off of like there
are four heads and their necks cuz they
went to Jersey high school yeah I
brother played against them in high
school I went and I took the
the twins can communicate and I just
decided that the safety quarterback
combination it's more impressive when
they can communicate like I'm telling
you that's incredible like that's such a
Belichick thing to do they really can
you believe my brother and hit I mean
his high school your st. Joe's and
Jersey the two starting quarters were
the McCourty twins and then they had
junior galette at the end can you
imagine that it's just hilarious I know
because my brother had like six NFL
players on his team too that's what's
unbelievable it's that stupid Catholic
school of New Jersey crap speaking of
your brother let's call your brother's
father big Phil let's get him on the
phone oh what's he been up to oh I don't
know yell out you ask him man another
cool I mean this is where bb's on next
level like Belichick and forth the
fourth and 11 at the end of the game
it's like he realized if I blitz I know
what they do now I figured it out it's
the fourth quarter and if I blitz in
this formation here's their adjustment
and it became the fourth and 11 at the
end of the game and he just said fire
I'm gonna blitz and ice look over to the
one side I go okay what the hell is
Minnesota gonna do here because they're
not protecting everybody up the block
anybody and Gilmore's stepping inside
the X receiver and it's like he said
we're gonna blitz and they're gonna
throw the slant route site adjust and
they just knew and he was there and they
just like he threw it to Gilmore and
it's incomplete and game over yeah well
that was a very good explanation thank
you yes talking about New England you
know just how they're always next level
stuff and the things they do yep they
are they are it's it's you know gets
tiring to talk about it and people get
tired of hearing it but you know tough
what do you want to say right you know
film to watch every week a lot of the
times because I'm just like what do they
do this week yeah yeah well they got
they got it down on how to play here
they are reverting back to the way they
won their first Super Bowl let's get the
I formation nobody's seen it knows how
to defend it so let's do this I mean
it's really kind of hilarious is one of
their leading
snap guys on offense the last couple of
weeks has been Mike Devlin right
and I think I've always told you this
who the three most important people on
the team right yes you have you've told
us that story about Slater yeah that's
that that Slater and James Devlin that
Matt Slater and James Devlin the special
teams guy in the fullback and who's the
third we thought it was a Devin McCourty
yeah Cory yes you know what I'm
realizing right now pretty good dog but
you know I'm really impressed you
remember that Adam oh you told you told
me on the flight to Minnesota - I did I
have a way you know when you talk about
football all your life you are going to
repeat yourself a few times like you
can't remember anything so I have to
keep reaffirming to you the facts
we got a daddy cigars I'm just looking
right now and teams tend to lose a lot
after they play the Patriots I wonder if
the Patriots show the blueprint of the
weakness of everybody's offense because
you know the Jets they lost the next
week to play the Titans and the Titans
go on like loose they came back and beat
the Jets they weren't good they beat the
they beat the Packers the Packers have
been rough ever since I don't know if
they kind of show the blueprint for
everybody else or they they exhaust you
be one other thing I would think you get
yourself so up to like what Dad you've
talked about a few weeks teams get
themselves up for that oh we gotta go
crazy this the big game is the Patriots
oh and then you lose it's such an
emotional letdown and everything that
goes with it well it's a letdown
emotional letdown no matter what win or
lose but if you win you know that
momentum sometimes
excuse me can carry you through but that
is definitely a case that when you play
them yeah it's it's a special week
because most the time it is you know the
425 or a night game whatever and
especially you go up to New England to
beat them there you know I mean it's you
prepare and do everything and you're so
tuned in because of why because you're
scared right because you know if you're
not tuned in you will lose get
embarrassed and all the others things
that go with it so but overall that
Minnesota game what a disappointment I
know it was 10 to 10 the second half but
still disappointing yeah
finn's upfront for the Minnesota Vikings
- it just seemed like the I know the
stats I didn't care what they say but
just watching the game and watching the
flow that they just got physically
dominated that's a front which was the
most shocking thing of all in the game
to me uh yeah I hear you I mean never
even got close to Brady and pass
protection and yeah might have not just
been great Smash Mouth running but they
did you know what did they do they ran
for 160 yards nonetheless well you know
if you do that every week in the NFL
your records gonna be you're gonna win
well over 10 games I know that yeah
right I mean one of my complaints about
the Vikings dad at times is just that
they're not multiple enough with their
defense it's not okay yeah listen I'm
sitting here trying to figure out how
can the Baltimore Ravens beat the Kansas
City Chiefs yeah yeah it's it's like I'm
trying you know I want to try to find
ways and right and let's talk about it
because I can give you a few right now
you can yeah so I don't know if you
happen to watch that Baltimore Ravens
Atlanta Falcons Phil get to it your son
will tell you that the drives themselves
were what were so impressive eight for
75 ten nine for 60 ten for whatever if
they're able to keep that defense on the
field and have those great pass rushers
of D Ford and Justin Houston even Chris
Jones constantly going damn it Gus
Edwards up the middle Lamar Jackson to
the outside and we get six a minute
drive seven minute drive I'm a firm
believer that if they go to halftime and
it's Chiefs 14 Ravens 13 it's a bad spot
for the Chiefs because then every
possession we can't afford the overthrow
to tyree kill we can't afford that one
Travis Kelce drop across the middle the
Ravens to me are becoming the Cowboys
where it's welcome to the Thunderdome
we're gonna pound you and every time you
touch the ball there's more pressure on
you because you might not get it back
for eight minutes
very good point great point and and and
I agree that you know but I'm looking
more on the other side is
first thought yeah like really tackle
that too how can you stop this Kansas
City offense right cause it is the only
one in the NFL the only one don't tell
me about the Rams I don't want to hear
about the Chargers and I don't hear
about anybody else because nobody can do
what Kansas City does on offense they
can as you guys know it's down the field
it's to the sidelines that and you've
got a mobile quarterback who is a
tremendous thrower on the run so that's
how do you defend I'm watching them now
yeah they're great at disguise they do a
lot of stuff they did I think that helps
and look to number one key make my homes
in my opinion make him stand in the
pocket and beat you from there right
because here's what I noticed going with
look a nice it hit me today
he throws when you make him stand there
he'll kind of like oh it's not their old
I got it he throws it and it's trouble
right he got away with a few against the
Oakland Raiders he did a couple they
were completed I go man that could have
been intercepted that has so many in but
if you let him throw in rhythm and hit
the ones that are open and they're not
if you let him get outside the pocket
then you're gonna lose and that's the
way I look at the the Ravens can they
disguise enough can they confuse him
enough can they keep him in the pocket
if they do that I think he will throw
the ball to the defense and able make
place right yeah one
I'm leaving the other part which is yes
it's difficult to but I think you are
away from in a weird way I don't think
the Ravens have that many great pass
rushers and because of that the muddled
rush actually accomplishes what Phil
wants them to do by accident Mart oh
wise one because you're exactly right
they're not going to go flying at him
because why they don't have those guys
yeah so in a weird way yeah in a weird
way their weakness becomes their
strength in this matchup I you know I
really do believe that and I do believe
that you know what they do down in
Baltimore there's just enough stuff
moving on you know Eric well he's trying
to be
Polamalu back in his day and he's he
gets close to it sometimes yeah pretty
cool there and it the other thing about
the Baltimore Ravens the numbers are
just astounding right the D the team is
kind of did you have you listened to
John Harbaugh speeches after the game no
why
oh my gosh you know we we do that on
Sunday we they beat the Falcons he's in
the locker room and is he is ready to
explode I can't even give you I can't
even say it words we ran about 50 times
you know and he's not just talking to
his team he's talking to the critics
oh the Ravens and there are people and
all that and you won't fire me
well and you know I'm gonna tell you and
the team when you can tell when they're
listening to him they're on fire right
that's pretty exciting and it's it's I I
forgot where I was gonna go with that
but just the fact although what it was
that this are what's the best part of
the we look at the Baltimore Ravens what
do we think of their size sizes okay
yeah physicality right yeah sure your
defense is the strength of your team
let's play to our defense right and
that's what they're doing now more than
anybody could ever do by having Lamar
Jackson in there running the football
and just keeping their defense rested
ready to go and their time a possession
and number of plays and all that other
stuff it is reversed big time in the
last three weeks now I know the
competition was great this will be
different right and so it's good you're
really excited to watch this game Sunday
you're gonna enjoy watching Baltimore
just steamroll Atlanta I mean it's it's
actually fun to have fill its role your
son came in and he goes he looks at me
and he goes Baltimore Atlanta Lefko
bludgeoning and he just kept saying the
word bludgeoning I said something Sunday
as we were talking about next week's
game he but watch the end of the four
o'clock games and we weren't going to
come back on the air probably so we all
stand in front of monitors and we just
you know and they've all of a sudden
somebody's Kansas City Baltimore Kansas
City next week and I go yeah one team
wants a pillow fight the other one I
forgot I forgot what the other word I
said
they all stared laugh I said yeah I
remember that was a good one but I can't
remember the other part - street fight
knife fight
no gun fight one wants to fight it with
the pillow all I wants to smash it ahead
with a sledgehammer yeah that works it
was better than that
but it's Beauty and the Beast it is so I
mean there's a lots of lots of words to
say about this game and I think that's
what makes it so intriguing and you tell
me you give me an answer this okay
what will you think if the Ravens go in
there and win this game and wouldn't the
style that they've been wanting games
what would be your impression with it
divert if there's a first thought Chris
what's your first thought then I'm gonna
give my first wouldn't be watch out for
watch out AFC the Ravens are for real
and my first thought would be holy crap
John Harbaugh is gonna be an amazing
coach for the Packers next year
absolutely my question is if they go
three and one down the stretch and they
end this year at ten and six and go to
the playoffs and push someone around I
know that like the Ravens been planning
all year to kind of end this but uh hey
you got a rookie quarterback and you got
this guy and it's kind of clicking now
like we figure it out wait babe first I
want to hear what his answer was gonna
be what he thought yeah did Baltimore
wins I just want to hear that part I
just think it's gonna be the most
exciting thing for football yeah it will
be great I mean here we go we got this
new way and it just kind of brings it as
a you know play again there's so many
ways to get this thing done you know so
many ways to skin a cat you know that
old phrase yeah and how about that
really running that the football is
taking over the lead again right now
really that's alum though it's it's
pretty amazing there and so so Phil I
need to go to history books with you
really quick okay so we had Josh Adams
on the show this week
Jamal Sue's excuse me excuse me wrong so
Jamal Adams is gonna be on the show this
week and we took him and we smash stuff
because since you're not allowed to hit
in the NFL anymore we wanted to release
his aggression by smashing things really
yes cuz you know we're here for the
players yeah and when Chris was talking
to him he goes look it was my dad it was
mark Ingram's dad and it was your dad
Jamal Adams it
dad going out there and kicking butt and
I'm curious what your what you really
remember about him because the stories
always seem to be man if George Adams
was healthy he would have been an
Alzheimer yes he would have been let me
think who would have been he would have
been David Johnson of the Cardinals but
I you know I don't know maybe faster and
shipped here I don't know he was he had
incredible hands and I've told you this
story and that would've been in 86 we
were building our offense around George
Adams right we were gonna use him and
all kinds of passing formations and just
think we had marked Bob all Zeke Mowat
too terrific tight ends then we're going
to have him as an inside you know flex
slot receiver power running back all the
throws screens and I was like man I
remember in training camp going man ha
we'll have a good year it'll be great
and of course he gets hurt and that was
basically the end so and I can remember
the play like it's yesterday that awful
feel that we practice on mr. for you
remember right as he got hurt
what's that he was in practice he got
practice he's running down the right
side
he goes to jump over a defender and I'm
gonna say the guy's name and the guy
raises his foot up off the ground and
trip seemed any lands off balance and
that was it
you know and you know he lived off the
field and well he'll be okay he'll be
okay I saw it as plain as day and he
wasn't okay but you know let me go like
this real quick though yeah would you
about John the Baltimore Ravens right
this is John Harbaugh team right this
fits who he is yeah he's a knucklehead
right he loves this that's what's going
you mean a knucklehead in a good way
just to clarify that like it's
knucklehead fight like this every day
right yeah I mean he wants to just see
he's if he could he'd punch the other
coach I mean two years he's a horrible
he's got the team that really truly fits
his mold and you know they got you know
Marty morning wing as a coordinator but
you know they got Greg Roman
drawed up all these plays and they're
not gonna run out of running place no no
and then when you stop him at the 35
Justin Tucker's guaranteed like watching
Ravens Falcons I look up I go damn
the Ravens kick three field goals
they're up to possession right there up
nine because every time they go over the
50 Tucker's knock it into a flame yeah
the same thing again you know the hidden
part you know John Harbaugh
is you know him and Bill Belichick and
of course now out in LA they're the Rams
their special teams are so great with
John awful right and you know they're
all fighting for it and I've told you
this one said Belichick was more than me
oh we finished number two these stupid
stats and special teams I'm like going
all right you finish to build instead of
one what's the big deal but he was all
he was all worked up over it you know
they did just wrong in the door a lot of
they calculated that we finished second
to the Ravens and it was so I was so
funny you know they take it they take
there if you watch Bill Belichick before
the game I've said this I noticed it in
their game against Minnesota who was he
talking to before the game almost the
whole time again
Joe judge it was Joe judge they went to
the defensive coordinator a little bit
after that but it's always special teams
the same with horrible I can remember
standing in the hallway in Baltimore and
they were working on kicking and they
had their kicking coach in there and so
the fact that they don't miss many field
goals not a surprise because you're
talking about an X special teams coach
who's involved there he's involved in
everything he's an old school coach what
a shock a hard ball that he's gonna go
out there and probably coach everybody
out of the field yeah Phil there's a
chance that coming up in the next few
weeks me your son and Josh might
actually watch a game together maybe one
of these Saturdays or something you are
you interested in joining us or do you
have work that you would do that I would
do that that'll be a lot of fun yes
that's right we got those Saturday games
coming in a few weeks any good ones I
don't even know I think there's a few
that are kind of signed kind of good
yeah we can always do like a wildcard
Saturday you're doing that - oh yeah I
don't think I don't haven't looked at
the schedule but I think well Don
wildcard said
there's a chance we won't even have a
game that one of those yeah I think
you're right I think one of them because
NBC will have one and then whoever will
have the other we get the sound cause we
have two games or not I don't know how
it works have it looked ahead it's a
dish you know I'm focused on this week's
game
don't worry about next week just win
this week I'm trying to do trying to win
the week
you're winning man all right bro all
right I'll ask you guys the questions I
mean what the hell yeah sorry guys ask
the question well no I mean I think
we're I think you should pay us this
sounds like it's therapy for you I mean
you just get to come on here and open
your mouth and just [ __ ] unleash the
Kraken you know I don't know maybe it's
because I watch you every morning or
three days a week thanks guys five-o you
guys are a little funny and which is
what's funny is because you're both so
odd in your own ways I mean boy you talk
about a Adam how about the two of them
three men you know my son's odd all this
creature habits and you know oh my god I
gotta have this exactly right here or
this and and of course well whatever
you're not like that are you no I'm the
opposite I just leave things everywhere
oh you could just you could roll with
whatever is going on oh yeah
are you the man that way to be
appreciates pal see you guys we will do
a wild card that would be great because
I will be done working by then one game
a week my god I'm going to know the
sisters of all the players and
everything that's all I do but that'll
be fun if we get to do it all right all
right have a good day yeah I'm realizing
as I'm saying this just going right we
don't even we don't even get a chance to
ask questions I feel like I feel like
the strategy next week I'd be right away
go all right Phil we're wrapping up
because then it's when we say that he's
like Oh what about this I don't think
it'll stop them
no that's what I'm saying because then
he knows us so he'll just power right
over us
I'm realizing that I my mahomes MVP rant
that's now on Bleacher Report's
Instagram I do not have come on a better
in a worse week
yes it's ugly like Drew Brees is facing
the Buccaneers defense and Pat mahomes
is facing the Baltimore Ravens defense I
am gonna get destroyed this week but if
it goes the other way and mahomes puts
up three blinds rebel against Tampa not
gonna happen you win this is what we
call poorly timed takes yeah I am gonna
be destroyed right so much so that I
want to clip this out as evidence that
I'm aware of the fact that I'm going to
get first of all it's a season-long
discussion you're talking about work and
we're all such prisoners at the moment
it's always about oh this week he sucks
this week he was the best quarterback in
football but this one week he sucks so
no longer can he be the MVP I am I mean
I'm actually I got juiced up talking
about Ravens Chiefs I don't anymore
that's gonna be really good alright well
let's go to Raiders offense versus the
Chiefs defense yeah had some people on
YouTube reach out and say what's up with
the Chiefs defense I even had some
people reaching out in the DM z-- going
look Derek Carr out before and Patrick
mahomes that's what I was getting in my
DMS by who who are you friends with
anyone can DM you I don't know but some
of your friends they're carson wentz
takes and these things i mean it's my
role to listen to the people as a man of
the people you are a little bit of
leadest i am someone that Hobnobs with
the locals and they tell me their
opinions and unbiased i give them to you
right yeah i don't know about that take
their I mean mahomes was gosh just the
amount of special throws he makes in
every game it's just it's it's off the
charts I mean he even missed a few that
would have been missed a few or two had
to dropped
I mean wide open yeah I mean so yeah and
I'm not gonna say that that Derek Carr
outperformed a first line of sims's
notes fanuc hit me Raiders offense
always finds a way to f it up right
always I mean this week it was the
three-run
back fumbles right I mean there they
moved the ball the whole game on the
Kansas City Chiefs I mean that they're
never gonna be stopped they're gonna go
down and get a field goal at least on
every drive and is that the Raiders
offense or the Chiefs defense this is
the Chiefs chief I'm saying I'm saying
oh then never being stopped is that more
Chiefs defense not able to stop yes
where the Raiders offense somewhat
clicking no I mean the Raiders offense
rant at least ran the ball well showed
some like we're gonna do this and beat
you up front and there's some what
healthy up front as far as you know some
of their guys there so they did some
good things but you know the Chiefs are
just all over the place then defense I
don't know what any but what I want to
like say I guess if I just had to sum it
up in a like a a one phrase thing I
would just go I don't really know what
the Chiefs are trying to accomplish on a
weekly basis on defense I don't know
what the game plan is you have the word
Y written here like five I'm sure
because like they're doing this why why
I just there's no ever I can never come
up with a logical reason to go wait why
are they doing this I don't I don't
understand it why is there five garlic
guys on this side of the field guarding
two people and then the other side of
the field is two on two I don't you know
that's what I want to go like it's five
on two over here we got all these guys
pushed over here and then the whole
field is one-on-one with two other guys
like just little things like that that
constantly frustrated me about you got a
you got a WTF Hitchens and here on the
touchdown I mean okay that's Tampa - I
mean you you know my pitch even knows
Hitchens role and the Tampa - is get
back as fast as you can you're the
middle safety that's what you are you
are the middle deep safety Tampa - if
Jon Gruden always used to say is really
three deep for under that's what it is I
mix it right it's three deep or under
except it's the two safeties and the
middle linebacker down the middle and
then you get the two linebackers in the
corners that are underneath right so
it's three deep four he's Tampa -
they're like on the 30-yard line and he
decides to get to the ten and stop and
turn around and let me look at the
quarterback and Jared cooks running
right down the field bio him and goes
right by him it's always Little Miss
mick mixup and everything they do how
big of a deal will Eric Berry coming
back be I think it will be a big deal as
far
he's by far going to be their best
player in the secondary or in the
backend in general including linebackers
every time I read your notes like oh god
damn it I think so gonna lose in the
first that's what scares me
I mean you know if they don't lose in
the first round it's only gonna because
the offense has put so much pressure on
whoever they're playing that they just
can't keep up but yes it's it's things
like that it's you know inconsistent run
fits at times where I just go I don't
know what to say it's weird
red zone approach right did you read
what I wrote there you know okay they
they are in the red zone and they rush
three and they drop eight they got eight
back ok that's great so just drop back
in an eight-person zone and play zone
but they're like playing zone over the
middle and they got the two guys on the
outside still playing man-to-man well
with a three-man rush and the middle of
the field being wide open the
quarterback eventually is gonna go back
to the receivers and go ok I've been
sitting back here for seven seconds now
can he shake this average DB that they
have at corner covering them ok BAM then
the next play is four-man rush at the 8
yard line and they double the two slot
guys ok and the other the other three
guys are just on an island by themselves
and they're all like at the goal line or
above like they're not even in the end
zone keeping people in front of them
like that makes no sense you want to
keep people in front of you in the end
zone because nobody can get behind you
it's the end zone mmm there's the fans
there so why wouldn't you be back and
then go let me read the quarterback and
react and run up right so that you left
this game really frustrated I've been
frustrated with Kansas City that's why
you've heard me in some weeks say
they're the fourth best team in football
and things like that cuz I don't have
faith that their defense can stop a
quality offense that's where I get
really scared for them yeah yeah all
right let me just make sure there's
anything else before we move to Chargers
team I mean hey you know Jones and D
Ford are amazing we do have to say that
they're amazing they can dig the roads
is really special right he's like
Fletcher cop he's like a carbon copy
he receives school same body yeah when
he wants to take over your guards seven
yards the
does Andy Ford is real good I'm not
gonna say he's the best pass rusher in
football and it's a thing those guys
make one play the Chiefs coming by for
you're exactly right but the back seven
of course is extremely disjointed and
just not talented and like I said in my
notes third dial of defense oh this we
play called cover three last play let's
call it Tampa to this play like I don't
know why but it just feels right at
second and try something exactly so I
just don't get that at times and I guess
that's it
charger stealers and I'm currently
looking at Chargers offense be some
other run Fitz man I don't even know
what they're expecting there's the last
thing about that like three receivers to
the left
everybody Chiefs no chiefs defense like
and I mean the Raiders ran the ball down
them like they were like the 60 Packers
I just I mean what what did they run for
in the game about how many yards total
they ran for a hundred and seventy-one
yards geez yeah so it was just like
they're they asked their player they've
lined up a defense is where I go I go
you can't defend this schematically you
cannot defend this like how can you line
up with three receivers to the left and
the tight end to the right and everybody
on the back seven kicked over to the
three receivers side and there's no run
defenders and the CD gap so you're
telling me to the other side but to the
daily fantasy players out there right
Gus Edwards is a good buy for Sunday I
would think I would think so yes
I really would or do you think Lamar is
gonna be running on the line I don't
know it's gonna be both I mean I don't I
can't envision Kansas City stopping
Baltimore a whole lot I don't you know
and and like I said there it's okay load
the box and stop the run Lamar is good
enough to throw the ball and be people
with his arm if you're gonna play
one-on-one with are you okay I look up
the spread really quick yeah I got what
game do you want to for I just looked it
up Casey Casey Baltimore Casey minus six
and a half minus six and a half I went
to load up on
yeah so that's that - six-and-a-half
number though right that's can happen
six and a half means because I'll wear
it where it's gonna go it means Vegas is
the there's something weird about it
yeah for the favorite yeah they don't
want to give it that touchdown because
you never want to cross the number
there's certain magic numbers in games
it open seven ten it opened Kansas City
- eight and a half and now it's kind of
like money's betting on Baltimore early
yeah really good if you got if you got
Ravens plus eight and a half yeah that's
an amazing is that they were all the top
of that I just said in gambling pay
attention when it crosses the numbers
right when it crosses three seven ten
that crossed seven we went from eight
and a half to six and a half that's a
that's a score change right that's
monster
it really is you're right it's the score
change I mean I wish I would have got in
on that right yes that just shows you of
a guess right now is still doubt in
Baltimore I mean it ended up but you
know Atlanta it was - - yeah it's hard
to quantify them that's the problem I I
mean the other thing that Kansas City
does - at times they ask their D tackles
- to gap you know can't do it well we
got to move on okay guys Chargers
Steelers yeah
the first thing I'm seeing the first
question I have for you is what the hell
happened to the Steelers defense in the
second half not that much not that mud
punt return upon return was huge I mean
the Chargers only had the ball one drive
in the third quarter they only had the
ball once they went down and scored a
touchdown they put a drive together
really I think what happened in the
second half is if I can boil it down to
one thing it would be this the Steelers
were the better football team
the Steelers should have won the game
I'll make that bold statement right
there if it's the second week in a row I
came away turning the film off going man
the Steelers were no doubt in my mind a
better team on the field and they blew
it it wasn't like the other team
outplayed them or out hit them or had
some schematically that truly exposed
that it was mistakes by Pittsburgh all
night long and some unlucky stuff too
but I think what they did in the second
half more than anything as they said
let's stop trying to
in the box with Pittsburgh let's let's
get outside the box okay
let's spread the field that was really
the big thing right this started off the
game thinking they're gonna do two tight
ends and fullback and tailback and
play-action pass and throw it and
Pittsburgh was like sure if I know you
mean we can keep our front seven in the
game and you want to play that with us
hosta can stay in yeah right and you
know then they got duper they can do
creative things off of that and it's
just their game I mean now you got to it
and Hayward and jayjay I mean tjy and
Dupree and they're just they're good up
there those are some dogs I mean dogs in
a good way so I think that's the thing
that in the second half they said let's
stop this crap we don't have Melvin
Gordon this week either let's get into
more shotgun sets spread the field and
make Pittsburgh play in space which is
still a big question mark about
Pittsburgh Pittsburgh's defense is
better than years past against defending
the pass but they're still not like the
best past events I've seen and they're
still reluctant to play man-to-man at
times because they just don't have
enough of those guys on their roster
that false start oh my gosh I know what
was it like to watch it on film well I
mean it's so blatant and obvious I think
that's the thing that bothers me more
than anything I mean it just was a clear
count in front of everybody else I'll
say this I don't think it really
affected the play in general you know
it's hard to totally tell Mike Hilton
did take a another hop look into the
backfield I think maybe to go wait did
they call false start or not but either
way they had the right play dialed up
against the right coverage was gonna be
very tough and Philip Rivers threw a
perfect football but that was blatantly
a false start and really the only bright
spot for the Chargers on offense in the
first half I mean that was it there was
nothing else hmm I was gonna switch it
over to the Steelers offense because I
see something here that's interesting
yeah there is a personnel that you
believe puts the most dangerous Steelers
offense on the field right and it is 12
yes who was on the field for the
Steelers and 12 personnel yeah I me
because I don't think you know we we all
can agree that the Steelers are
their third receivers you know who was
it Switzer Darius Hayward Bey can you
explain 12 for anyone that doesn't know
I go I'll get there and I mean James
Washington right I mean he wasn't in the
game the other night I guess he's in the
doghouse for what he did right which I
understand he's a one-trick pony anyways
but 12 personnel is one back to tight
ends and then there's always five
skilled guys on the field so that means
there's two left over for the receivers
so it's one back to tight ends two
receivers and if it's twenty-one that's
two backs one tight end and then of
course two receivers cuz it's up it's
always the subfile
but this is 12 and yes I do think this
is their best personnel set as just far
as players on the field so that means
you're gonna have juju a be the running
back right Vance McDonald and jesse jane
and Jesse James that's right I think
that's their best I think that's their
best 11 on offense if I'm them and of
course to me they should go New England
of 2011 style Aaron Hernandez Gronkowski
right I know Aaron Hernandez is not like
a great name to bring up but I'm just
talking about the player and the actual
schematics of one felt awkward I know it
is awkward and I mean gosh I knew him
personally so trust me it's more awkward
for me than anything but it's a you know
they have a good offensive line they can
run the football so they can put those
guys in and overwhelm you with their
strength and power in the run game but
also can put you in that bind to go
Vance McDonald the Jesse James can split
out and be effective in the pass game I
just think it's something that they
should bring to the offense more I don't
like them as much they got away but they
move the ball all night on the Chargers
and never really stopped them you know
but I do think against the better teams
that's going to be their best matchup
and I still think they should have
stated in a more the other night I think
they would have worn down the Chargers
event just was the other big thing that
I took from your notes on this case yeah
when the Steelers kept their big people
on the field the Chargers were in
trouble yes and so my question that is
for you is against teams like the Ravens
maybe in the playoffs or if the Texans
load up where we see the Patriots power
running game is the way to attack the
Chargers by keeping bigger formations on
the field I do are they have smaller
defense they are there are smaller
defense
you know the Denzel Perryman is out for
the year you know I don't know what's
going on with Brandon me bein but he
hasn't played the last few weeks he has
some personal issue he's dealing with
you know you talked about quarry luge
it's out for the year yeah they're a
little thin up there they don't have big
middle linebackers as is so I guess when
you kind of let Bosa and Ingram rush
that's when they're more dangerous but
if they're kind of in the Box getting
pounded it's no question it's now cuz
they're it's not what they're built for
so that would certainly scare me a
little bit yes if they got in the
playoffs and had to deal with those type
of teams it could be it could be a tough
day sledding for their group yeah I
wanted to see the the teams they have up
coming if anybody could try and take
advantage of that yeah but you know as a
whole gosh it's just you know big been
missing the deep throat of Justin hunter
Big Ben's dumb interception New England
should have been up no worse okay at
it's very worst I said New England
Pittsburgh Chargers play the Ravens in
three weeks see that could be had all
the interest yes but at the know worst
halftime score should have been twenty
nine to seven Pittsburgh and
realistically probably should have been
33 to seven because he should have hit
Justin hunter for the wide open
touchdown that he missed right which was
unbelievable but the series before that
they were also down there and he threw
that dumb interception to gentleman
James too which you know I don't know
what the hell he was thinking or doing
or trying to get accomplished there the
guy was open he had him he's got a throw
and he threw like a fadeaway jumper and
the ball went nowhere and came out of
his hand funny if someone can explain to
me how dur when James lasted to that
point in the draft I still it's really
weird right I wasn't even a guy that was
as high on him as some of the other
people but even I was like he's top 10
or top 12 I mean he it is amazing that
he fell into their lap Browns Texans
yeah I know you watch this one on the
train yeah Texans what did you get more
confident after it or was it this is
just them beating up on the Browns no I
made where are they as a unit right now
yeah the Brett the Texans I think the
big thing to watch for is just the
development more of their pass game like
we've talked about do you see them well
it's just it's feast or famine it's run
the ball and then it's dropped back and
we look for a 20 yard completion it's
run the ball it's we drop back and we're
looking for another chunk play
in the past game and nothing's easy
nothing is easy like sometimes those
guys are open and becomes easy because
it's a great game plan or they call it
the right way all right something like
that but I'm just saying that to me are
things they need to fix a little bit
they need to find a few ways to get some
shorter easier completions in their drop
back pass game just in case but again
I'm trying to measure these teams
against the teams are going to have to
play in the playoffs and that's these
questions that I bring up I'm not
worried about what they'll do against
the Tampa Bay Buccaneers or somebody
like that I'm trying to say these are
the flaws of their team that are gonna
ride off football with good defenses an
extra break down exact half-court game
and basketball pretty much exactly right
hand usage and all that exactly right V
is it that do they have a lot of cross
like I don't I don't feel like I turn on
the Texans to see a lot of bunch no
they're not very really much like that
they're kind of when I see athletes at
tight end they do they got athletes its
head in they're trying to figure out who
they got to get as the slot receiver
DeAndre Carter looked very good so you
did I mean Watson's thrown the ball and
moving around I mean amazing is he
running enough there's a time or two
where I just go just go get a pocket
guy watch him and I go if they have to
play in New England in the pin the play
oh yeah I hope a coach can get in his
ear and go we need your wrist Ketil yeah
yeah yeah almost almost kind of run a
little bit too much right in the
beginning yeah and I think you know
he'll have that sense when that time
comes he's a gamer he is a gamer and
he's gonna know he's in New England and
he went balls out last year when he was
there remember in that game yes he did
Oh Texans defense how much fun is it to
watch I mean one of my favorite watches
I think you're in that agreement as well
it's the first year that we're getting
clowny watt and merciless together
healthy no doubt with honey badger in
the back end givin them attitude to
Covington and reader right and I think
everything we saw from that or thought
about of that game was really true like
this is Baker's never seen a defense
like that I'm sure did you sense that
well this front for the disguises the
game plan defense of a Romeo Crennel
where yeah this is cover four but you
haven't seen cover four like this we've
got a special cover for for you or
whatever it may be so yes
they made some incredible plays Baker
through really you know I knew I through
the three picks the one-handed
interception was amazing play that got
returned for the Pick six he threw an
under route that he shouldn't have
thrown I think that was Jonathan Joseph
that was really like just a bad one he
just shouldn't have thrown and I'm
trying to I'm blanking out on the third
int I'm gonna pull it up the Browns also
made some plays where Antonio Callaway
was gonna score like a huge touchdown
and fumbled in the end zone he had
another one where like they got one
called back I'm the same Drive same
Drive like they had a huge hole [ __ ] out
of the tap top called back Y of the
penalty right and then like throws
reality runs all the way down the field
and fumbles into the end zone strips at
the one-one you know that's the
difference between the Browns and the
text it is um but I'll just say this
once again for the Browns I really like
where the Browns are going and Baker
Mayfield is some player man is he some
player I mean he really is I don't give
a damn that they lost and he threw three
interceptions I'm just telling you what
he brings to the table as a top level
talent and going forward and he starts
to learn the nuances of the NFL and what
he can and can't get away with which he
will because you're smart guy
and he understands how to play ball I'm
just so impressed with him on a weekly
basis with composure in the pocket
movement in the pocket movement in the
pocket while keeping the eyes down the
field and his throwing is off the charts
it's off the charts I'm not saying it's
Patrick mahomes or Aaron Rodgers but
damn it's the next tier down Wow it's
that good yes it there's something that
you're gonna have to look at with your
college scouting going forward yes I
chickened out with it what no no this is
what it is there are some guys that
you've now said to Shawn Watson and
Baker Mayfield are the same right where
you go he's got the zip yeah I just
don't know if he can do it all the time
right
I felt like you said the same thing
about Jared Goff and we're starting to
see that too sure I feel like if you see
the zip right just go with it when you
when they get in the NFL yeah they're
gonna realize they got to do it all the
time
now there's gonna be like the Josh
Alan's where you're like this is special
yes this is special right but it's the
gamers like the the wick we knew that
the Sean Watson and Baker Mayfield work
gamer yes and you saw the zip and you
went I just don't know if I'm gonna get
it all the time like you said from Baker
it pops out of his hands it's not a
question right just know that it's gonna
be every time yeah yeah
no doubt that's what I think it is
definitely with the Sean for sure Baker
was a little of that a little of the
easiness of the completions he got in
Oklahoma time and the side scared me it
just scared me I thought it was you
don't have to defend that I was just
like I don't know I watched the Georgia
game and went oh yeah right I got scared
of some of those that's alright let's go
around the league some news and notes
yeah interesting situation in
panthersville Carolina defensive
coordinator Eric Washington demoted Ron
Rivera's gonna call the defensive plays
and defensive line coach Brady Hoke
assistant secondary quarterbacks coach
Jeff Emma Mora both fired
so the Carolina Panthers are on a little
downturn right now that sounds like a
complete defensive overhaul at every
level the defense has been demoted or go
yeah say those last two again who would
the Superman Brady Hoke yeah and Jeff
Emma Mora right
damned assistant secondary quarterbacks
coach yes so they're not happy with the
way their defense has been gashed for
the last four weeks basically they're
gonna change things up but okay Ron
Rivera is gonna get back in the game
this is where he got a head coaching job
anyways so okay yeah they've lit up a
number of big plays I don't have a great
feel for that Tampa game yet last week
so I'm not gonna be able to tell you a
whole lot of big Cam Newton errors
throwing balls and to play like three or
four no question I just I want to see I
don't know what happened to their
defense in the game itself and I guys
was scarce in the last few week 52 to
Pittsburgh
yeah lose 22 19 in Detroit and truly the
yardage there was the issue Detroit
marched up and down the field yes they
32 the Seahawks in 24 to Tampa Bay and
now they're playing at Cleveland oof
yeah be scary
next one the Packers coaching search
some quick hits here yeah
linebackers coach Winston Moss fired
after tweeting about Aaron Rodgers to
tweet was quote ponder this what
championship teams have our great
leadership
period it's not the offensive guru trend
it's not the safe trend find somebody
that's gonna hold number 12 and
everybody in this building to a hashtag
Lombardi standard period hashtag losing
sucks soon after he tweeted out the
Packers have informed me that they're
letting me go hashtag thanks Twitter
your point was the best my point is his
tweet is a hundred percent correct he's
right
I mean successful football teams
everybody's held accountable Joe Montana
was held accountable with Bill wash we
know Tom Brady's accountable to Bill
Belichick I mean all we ever hear is
about stories about how free agents are
shocked that Bill Belichick yells at Tom
Brady the same way he yells at the
seventh round pick in the draft
so yes Bill Parcells he certainly didn't
favor my father anyway Jimmy Johnson
wasn't favored and Troy Aikman or
anybody else either so yes that's what
great teams do everybody's accountable
in the whole building it's not just the
quarterback it's the equipment staff
it's creating the championship aura of
your football team now the championship
aura of a football team and a winning
culture doesn't have assistant coaches
tweeting out about what it takes to
become a winning culture or successful
know that I'm yet to see the linebackers
coach for the New England Patriots tweet
out anything since Bill Belichick taking
over was right which should be on
Twitter right and what right just saw a
great movie starring Jake Gyllenhaal had
to let you guys know like what are you
tweeting about yeah hashtag thanks
Twitter I don't know what else to say
here my question is yeah did that tweet
sound like championship teams have great
leadership it's not the offensive guru
the safe fine someone's gonna hold a
veil was that at Aaron or was that the
fact that he was the associate head
coach and he was not the interim head
coach yeah I don't because I will be on
right if I was the associate head coach
right which is usually a top like a
title they give people that are rising
up the coaching ranks and they're afraid
of losing and they call me associated
head coach because there's no other job
they can give them
because the head coaches and their we're
gonna we're gonna make them feel happy
if I'm the associate coach assistant
head coach assistant head cash and you
give it to Philbin right who is proven
in this league not to be a head coach
yeah I would be pissed yeah I don't
think I'd tweet about it right but do
you think it was more about being passed
over or upset about Aaron Rodgers not
being held accountable I don't think
it's I don't look at it as Aaron Rodgers
I don't I think he's tweeting that out
to go like no one man is above the team
or the whole team and he's just trying
to give you his thing that you know in a
great football team there's no star
that's ever just let off the hook or any
great franchise that way I'm sure he was
a little bitter I would have been being
stepped over as well but he also has
enough sense to know like come on you've
been around football a long time I was
shocked when I saw the tweet and I'm not
gonna lie I saw the tweet and I'm my
original thought was exactly what I just
told you that he's exactly right but in
that tweet he's actually being
hypocritical himself because he's doing
something a championship team wouldn't
do I didn't know he got fired until this
morning so I never looked at anything
last night so you know I've always asked
for coaches to be held to the same
standard that the players are when it
comes to discipline I got fired you got
fired good for them you know and the the
acting GM Marc Maron Marc Murphy the
Acting President and guten close they
don't want to hear that yeah they don't
want to hear that from an assistant
coach like you know it looks bad on them
and I heard someone call Brian guten
Cousteau guests get kissed gut kissed
like that the ends pronounce it is
something like that it's just it's not
that it's good couldn't could I also has
any human being ever looked like his
name more than Mark Murphy like when
Mark Murphy came on the TV I was like I
knew that and I didn't even need to see
a picture yeah it's pretty spot-on Chris
Carter says that Jim Harbaugh is trying
to get out of Michigan for either
Cleveland or green men Oh what do you
mean oh that's four years it's time to
go you're right Jim Harbaugh it's like
I'm gonna change this is gonna be a
long-term relationship right I just
thought hardball should stay and maybe
get a win over Ohio State I mean
right I mean urban is finally leaving
you have a chance got a chance now yeah
um I get it you know I think Jim
Harbaugh is a really good football coach
you know that I think he's also a really
overrated football coach I mean people
talk about him like he's Urban Meyer and
Nick Saban and he gets paid more than
them and I want to go whoa like hold on
he's really good and he knows how to
manage a football team and he makes them
tough and they're detailed but you know
again yeah I don't I just think it's
it's a little overrated in my fam I you
know I always go back to like he's
supposed to be an offensive coach his
offenses always think I'm getting a
weird feeling he's gonna get one of
these jobs whenever there's a big game
yeah I mean he could I get it it's gonna
make the fan base feel good if they get
him how would him and Aaron Rodgers get
along I feel like him and Baker Mayfield
could get along for a little bit right I
feel like him and Aaron Rodgers would
not get along at all I I feel like he'd
look at air and be like let's go
quarterback I need you and Aaron would
be like dude I don't want to go back to
college
yeah I know I I don't think he's as
College as you think but yes his
old-school thoughts who's he gonna bring
in as the offensive mind I mean it's
never changed the offense has been
horrible
everywhere I just I just don't think
people realize that the only thing that
saved him in San Francisco was
Kaepernick's ability to run and Greg
Roman put in the read option and the
quarterback design run plays that gave
them some offensive explosiveness from
that standpoint
Arians has come out and said I'm not
interested in the Packers job yeah I'm
only interested in the Browns I'm one it
makes sense the Browns are poised to
have a run and as you've mentioned
before when you're the Browns if you
take them to the playoffs yes you're a
saint
right you might get a seven-year
extension of that happens but what do
you think about Bruce Arians just coming
out and going not interested in the
Packers I think the Packers have a weird
power structure that to turn off to a
lot of coaches I think that's our the
Murphy's being like I'm the president
everything funnels to me no it's just
you don't have an owner that you can go
to and go this guy's crazy exactly right
there's no like there's no safe space
they're definitely not and you know the
owner is even though he's the owner he's
still
the owner and the leader in the building
when he's there and he's a presence and
he keeps everybody in line from that
step I think there's things there's a
lot of things there
you know everybody seems to always think
it's all about Rogers oh he's saying he
doesn't want to go there and coach
Rogers that's that's the first thing I
heard this morning he's just he doesn't
wanna go coach Rogers I mean come on he
coach Peyton Manning Ben Roethlisberger
Andrew Luck I mean nobody's more of a
diva than Ben Roethlisberger if he can
get along with him then he'll be fine
with Aaron Rodgers come on that's crazy
you know even back to the the moss tweet
yes you know it's the first thing is
they're always he taking a shot at
Rodgers can Rodgers just Rodgers not
held accountable can Rodgers not lead
the team I don't know Rodgers can't lead
the team until it comes time to lead the
team late in the fourth quarter and he
always seems to lead the team and
everybody goes we want him leading the
team but we're gonna blame him now if
we're not leading the team I don't know
I just I can't it's about I got a SPAD
offer if he the other names that were
mentioned a lot we spent some time on
him but I wanted to dive deeper Lincoln
Riley and also Kliff Kingsbury but
mainly Lincoln Riley and your point was
if you really look at the college
coaches that went on to have success in
the NFL they already had an NFL
background right so let me go over Bill
Walsh was one of those guys had success
in college went to the NFL spent 10
years with Paul Brown before he went to
Stanford right if you look at look Steve
Spurrier went from college to the NFL
didn't work out you mentioned Chip Kelly
didn't work out the guys that have
offensive masterminds it doesn't work
out sometimes Bobby Petrino College to
the NFL didn't work out Steve Mariucci
had an NFL background before he was
there in Green Bay with Holmgren and the
whole group right I'm trying to think
Jimmy Johnson not an offensive guy no
it's definitely not offensive guy Al
Groh didn't really work out Dennis Green
and yeah I mean Al Groh had an NFL
background anyways first right he was
under Bob Parcells staff he was as my
dad when I was growing up so that's your
main thing and Paul Brown you know I
mean it's hard to say he went from
college to the NFL the NFL didn't really
exist yeah as a different generation
there but your main thing is Lincoln
Reilly's offense isn't that advanced in
the NFL standard not at all and
Kingsbury just signed with USC right
right and I mean that's the first thing
I mean nobody was the offering
very a head coaching job in college he
was being offered an OC job but yet the
media was trying to say oh he might be
an NFL head coach why cuz he's handsome
and young and his team throws for a lot
of yards I'll say this Kingsbury and I
know we're talking more Lincoln Riley
here they both have the personality and
charisma and the ability to lead players
and be a head coach even in the NFL they
do have that in them like their guys
that I've met and I've been around I go
he's a head coach I could picture myself
in the meeting room listen to that guy
and I would respect them right and
there's other guys I've met where I just
like there's no way he can ever be told
my god she got hired as a head coach it
won't last long I'll be look at my clock
and usually I'm right there's been a few
maybe here or there that I've been wrong
about but the the Lincoln Riley thing
yes I guess at my base level what I want
to just say is college football is a
different animal there's 20 hour rule
there's only so much you can coach your
team and there's only so much the team
you're playing against can coach their
players too and I think if you know
everybody out there listen to this pod
and if we all got to sat down and we
watched big 12 football together and I
showed you you know Oklahoma State
Oklahoma State verse verse Oklahoma
I would watch the game and I go look
everybody look here's Oklahoma State
this is play 80 and you've seen this
coverage 65 times and the other 15 are
another coverage that are also very
simple so it's very easy let alone that
there's not a lot of a defensive good
players and in our NFL caliber in the
big 12 and his offense it's a spread
offense yes Oklahoma is always the most
talented team on the field in the big 12
right boys but all I'm saying at the
base level of this is they're just not
the offenses as expansive as people
think or think it looks on TV there's
just not a lot of different concepts
I'll finish my thought there's just not
a lot of different concepts within the
offense and when you break down the
offense like there's not as many plays
as you think now he knows how to call
the plays and tie some together and
certainly but I don't think you know the
offense has enough inventory is what I'm
saying Josh to hang in there against the
I fell quite yet I don't think he knows
how to use the full back and use that
part of the office the two tight end
look all of those things you can't just
get in the NFL go we're gonna run
shotgun and I'm gonna throw the ball and
run bubble screens to my receivers like
the NFL will catch on to you in two
seconds and you know I know they're all
looking for the young hotshot I get that
but McVeigh and Shanahan and McDaniels
are like all NFL upbringing from their
childhood from their family McVeigh
started with Gruden and then went with
Mike Shanahan and was under Kyle
Shanahan and then he went to the Rams
Kyle Shannon of course was with Gruden
as well and then went and worked for
Gary Kubiak and then went to his dad and
learned some more football before then
he even had to go a few other places
before he became the head coach but the
NFL background because you see more
complex defenses and you got to have
more complex offenses to match that at
times is a very important thing in this
aspect and like the two people left go
brought up would be my case in point I
mean the world was so excited when Steve
Spurrier left Florida and Steve Spurrier
went to Washington and they were like
this is going to be a revolution and
this Steve Spurrier he tore up the
preseason if anybody remember he scored
like 50 something points a little
Petrino did to build Palecek of the
Patriots he scored like 50 points in a
preseason game against debate Bill
Belichick and the New England Patriots
who like are the exact opposite where
they're like we're just playing this
coverage and preseason game number two
cuz I don't think my guys have cover two
down yet so we're not gonna move on
until then but what happened to Steve
Spurrier I played him his first year
there cuz I was in Tampa man that often
sucked I'm I don't know what other way
to say it there was 10 plays everybody
in the NFL knew his offense by week six
that's what I want Chip Kelly exactly
what happened to Chip Kelly at least you
guys had some talent to kind of
themselves prime my Jeremy Maclin DeSean
Jackson Michael Vick a good offensive
lineman for a little while right but I
can also remember yes the lead caught on
the Chip Kelly in a hurry and I can also
remember them going to scrimmage a team
and the priests
in his second year and I just remember
him talking to one of the coaches and
just gone I don't get it
I mean why everyone's calling this guy
an offensive genius I mean he's this guy
this one coach just goes Nathan they got
to run plays it's two then he goes and
from what I've seen it's eight pass
plays that's it it's the whole offense
and of course everybody caught on and
you've seen now and even college
football's caught on his offense they do
him crap they're either the lip flap was
the best so I was against the Eagles
slow-mo that was my rant on Lincoln
Riley can do it at some point but I just
think he has to expand his horizons and
inventory so I know that a lot of Saints
fans hate me yeah they do not like me
showing the club Saints fans I just want
to say this the Saints right now what
are they
ten and two yeah in my opinion mm-hmm
the Saints are going to win the next
four games they're gonna beat the
Steelers at home they're gonna beat the
Panthers twice they're gonna beat the
Bucks they're gonna finish this year 14
and to the rams are going to lose a game
before the end of the year and the
Saints are going to have home-field it
you're gonna get a number one I believe
the Saints are going to the Superbowl
yeah I thought about this today yeah I
believe that no one in the NFC is
capable of going into New Orleans and
beating the Saints right I also think
that let's say the Rams don't lose a
game and they play in LA I don't see the
Rams beating the Saints in LA I don't
think they have enough of a home-field
advantage no I think that the loss to
Dallas will actually spur the Saints to
make the Superbowl run yeah I believe
that yeah that's I mean hey listen I
hear you I'm not gonna quite I'm not
quite getting him out of the woods of
the Rams yet I'm not afraid of the Bears
no I'm not afraid of the Vikings I know
the easier if they play the Cowboys
again I'm more confident right you're
gonna win this time right but I I know
the Rams are really good I just think
the Saints are gonna have that number
yeah because when it comes down to it
Jared Goff or Drew Brees in that big
game both of them are executing the
systems yeah I got more faith
well every team has their kryptonite in
the NFL there's nobody that's above
kryptonite okay and the NFL at some
point you're gonna play a team that
goddamn we don't match up well with them
and I do think for the Rams it is the
Saints I think they're one of the
biggest kryptonite's they have because
they have the offensive line that can
and they have Andrew speed who could
slow down the Aaron Donald and all that
they have the creative attack to mess
with the Peters and the Aqib Talib 's
and the the LaMarcus joiners on the back
ends and then they have a good defensive
run stopping defense that can go oh I
know you guys are awesome at passing but
we can keep people back in the pass game
a little bit cuz we're pretty good at
stopping the run up front so baby code
matches up and they have a code yeah
that's one of the few guys the NFL you
can go it's a wash write him and McVeigh
right not a lot of teams could yeah I
mean III hear your thought all the way
I'm a little still torn between who's
better the Rams are the Saints it's very
close to me I have days where I go it's
the Saints but I have days like today
where I want to go out maybe the Rams so
lead makes interesting it doesn't make
it interesting Thursday Night Football
let's do our preview now so that people
can be prepared for the game Jaguars
versus the Titans all right
Jaguars played their best game of the
year on defense last week I watched that
film and they were phenomenal I mean you
know I know they were they're pissed off
and there's coaching changes and
whatever else and hey the Colts were
missing tight end play so they didn't
get to get in some of those sets that
burn Jacksonville the first time around
but I'm just talking about from the
front for to being sound in the back end
where they didn't blow anything they
played really good football game against
the Colts last week and I don't even
know what Titans team we're gonna go
that's the Kaiser maybe the most
confusing team in football I like the
second year in a row how was Cody
Kessler Cody can he put up six points
yeah no I did not watch that part of it
enough to tell you that all the way all
I know is what I could tell you from
this point the like I said on Monday I
think I said about Monday maybe I didn't
but the Colts should have been prepared
to win that game nine to six they could
have won the game that if they just on
the three
for thin shorts they have in
Jacksonville territory if they just
kicked the feel though they're gonna win
the game hmm I didn't watch the other
side of the ball yet I didn't always
seem to have the Jaguars number they do
seem to yes they do
beat him five out of the last six yeah
did it earlier this year in Jacksonville
this games now in Tennessee I mean I
think this is just gonna be the ugliest
defensive struggle I think this game
what was the score earlier this year was
it 12 to 9 or earlier this year it was
it was at Jacksonville's 9 to 6 tight I
just don't be shocked if that's what it
is again I mean I don't imagine Cody
Kessler in that group they do have 4 net
this week but that's a tough matchup for
their often so the Titans D right and
then the other side of course we know
it's gonna be tough sledding for the the
Titans offense versus the Jags do you
takin well the line when we saw it a few
days ago was Titans - four and a half
still four and a half it's a lot of
points for for a matchup that kind of
goes back and forth like this if I'm
gonna do some of my research right here
live last year
they beat the crap out of the Jaguars in
Jacksonville and at home only won by
five very end of the year and that was
the Mariota standing over the defense
game and proclaiming I think that I look
at Tennessee and they come off a game in
which they roar back at the end
Jacksonville beats Indy in their best
performance I know it's a tough one
cuz like it can be one of those games
where it's it's six three yeah it's six
six and finally Jacksonville's defense
has been on the field too much and they
let up a play and all of a sudden they
lose 13 to 6 or they lose 16 to sit I
think in the end the Titans have more to
play for yeah and I I think that I think
that Jacksonville's in spoiler mode and
they got such a good spoil last week
that I don't think they spoil again I
think this is gonna end up being 16 9
Titans 16 9 Titans and we know we're
getting fournette right this way yes so
you're saying 16 9 you're saying that
how do you cover how do you think that
for net would run against this Titans
defense I do I think he'll be able to
run on them a little bit I
really really really worried about is
them just being able to throw the ball
you know again DPS were able the things
they do they can be very I'm going 16:9
Titans yeah that's pretty good I think
I'm gonna go 13-9 Titans cover I'm gonna
go to the cover this might change by
tomorrow - all right let's go to some
fan questions really quick Steeler
Nation 84 thank you so much Tonio Brown
I feel like I feel like I've learned to
talk to Steeler Nation 84 so many times
a question for the pod we always hear
Sims reciting offensive play calls and I
like that but I'm curious as to what a
defensive play call sounds like do they
just say it coverage or is it like the
offense where there's parts for
different groups yeah its parts for
different groups it'd be like six yeah
break 57 over to will or like some stuff
like that I don't even know if I can
give you a legit defense up I call it's
not like what the deal is doing with the
linebackers will be because like the
number will say like this is the
alignment we're in upfront and the over
is gonna say something about the
linebackers and then you know the last
number you hear is gonna be about the
coverage so I never just yell just cover
them and but it is they have Cohen man
up they have caught you know a lot of
words for you know what stunts they want
to bring and things like that you know
we're gonna go Roger Roger 11 robber
Roger Roger 11 robber and then they
break the huddle like it's like [ __ ]
like that we're you know we're gonna go
twist double reed cover for and break
the huddle that's a you know and it's
like twisted or a twist upfront double
reed means if they go from one formation
to the number of formation we got a
check out of it like so it's kind of
defensive calls like that it's like six
seven words that each word has kind of
some in depth of meaning that sounds so
much better yeah well there's more
moving parts on the NFL I mean when I
was a quarterback in the NFL used to
just go man it must be amazing to play
on defense just go there's ball me go
tackle ball there's receiver me cover
receiver like I used to be jealous of
them that's why the the part of a
football game that makes all the fans
feel smart yeah is when the
quarterback kind of looks and does
something right and then the announcer
goes and then the play happens and he
throws a go route for a touch and he
goes so what happened there is he saw
the coverage and he gave the signal
everyone's like I understand football he
saw it and he said you just go and I'm
gonna throw it to you that's when we
feel smart when we can explain things
sure this is a question I need your help
on Josh this is from Nadav Jenna so
Jenna so there is a miked up video of
Darius Leonard where he does a drill and
says that he hates it do you remember
what the drill was did he put it in the
night into the job was there any drill
that Sims can think of that he just
hated Oh what I know the first one that
I'm I might like you know the damn thing
you got a run through oh those things
are no crap so I will say this so it's
the running back drill where you hold
the ball and there's these little things
around like I mentioned earlier bowling
yeah right and you run through them my
whole life I thought they were like
floppy yeah like I was like oh because
when you see like Marshall Faulk run
through there like food a little food
the first time I went with you to
training camp yeah I went out actually I
was covering a high school football
practice in Louisville and I walked up
and I like touched one and I was like ow
yeah and then I tried to walk through
and if you try and do it slowly it's
almost worse and I was like this is
awful right why did you have to do that
as a quarterback ball protection yeah so
wait when did you first start doing that
I mean I'd probably did it in high
school a few times college maybe a few
times
NFL almost never until Jeff Fisher Josh
McDaniels because it's New England and
we're gonna work on ball security every
day not just when we fumbled the ball
and then go we need to work on our ball
security which is the correct way
exactly of course it is it just sucks
like corrects right every day you would
have what like bruises on your elbows I
mean yeah we didn't always run through
that thing but we're always gonna do
some sort of drill of ball security
always every day but yeah I would be
like man I got to go through this and
I'd be so worried about my private parts
and all those thing
right at that area right at that area so
and you're like that thing hits home I'm
in trouble I'm done for the day but it's
one of those things dog fast ER you run
through it the less it hurts yes if you
go through slow you start to feel those
plastic things hit you and you go it's
like it's like any gauntlet right if you
run through a gauntlet you're not gonna
get hit by as many things exactly walk
it Shane yeah Shane that was that was
probably like the worst thing and then
punishment at Texas punishment in Texas
was brutal if we lost a game at Texas
the next day was going to be miserable
for us how dare we lose and we were
gonna go out and do things like bear
crawl oh yeah you've always mentioned
bear crawl ten yards do five up-downs
bear crawl ten yards do five up-downs up
and down the field until we couldn't do
it anymore
Josh what did you ever have any anything
in sports that practice wise because I
know mine high school soccer we used to
have like it was a three-mile run to
church down the road and we would have
to do that timed and then if we lost or
if we did it too slow we would they
would just be like just do it again yeah
that term I know left goes all the way
what was my least favorite drill
suicides mine were actually 1717 17s
were just running up and back the the
short part of the basketball court
sideways or sideways thank you but
having to do 17 in a minute oh and I
always would sit there and I'd go the
worst part when you're getting punished
is when you know that you're not even
capable of finishing on time and it's
not if I have to do it again it's I'm
going to do it again yeah I am NOT fast
like that's not like I am I'm okay at
Short area quickness and even that's a
struggle right but I would be like guys
the quickest I can do is 13 yeah and I
would just be running all the time
asides oh man the worst would be it's a
lot like when we were playing The
Melvins in that M&M game yeah and I
thought that I was making really good
time and I would look up and see like
people already going the full suicide
back you like oh I like stressing out I
have no pace yes
those were killer yeah um all right we
are a rat I have that was it just to
okay again check out Sims and luff go we
hung out with Jamal Adams best safety in
the NFL he talked about how even he is
tired of seeing other defenses posing in
the end zone and that's the Saints thing
which I thought was very interesting
yeah and we literally smashed crap and I
almost broke Jamal's eyeball yeah and
you'll see that but we have our bet show
and I'm telling you I don't even know
the numbers but I know it's close I know
it's very close it's gonna be great for
Sims he's not homie for Federer good
evening everybody
I am the lef koe man I know I told you
to listen to metha man I want to
apologize if you didn't know what the
first 50 seconds were gonna be it's a
little intense so maybe he's kept ahead
I'll holler at you guys later
they say Lou tang